hey youtubers is charlie so HBO released
synopsis for the first three episodes
for Game of Thrones Season five so this
is going to be a breakdown of that even
though it's just speculation careful for
spoilers and new round of the giveaway
starts now because they haven't tape
you'd the streaming service yet it's
still a copy of the season four DVD or
blu-ray whichever you want so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go so episode 1 the
worse to come a lot of different Wars
being implied here there's the East the
West the south and the north when it
says Cersei and Jaime adjusts to world
with that Tywin in King's Landing
obviously Cersei and Jaime talking about
Tywin's funeral last season I know they
had that really controversial moment
when they were in the set and they're
having sex over Joffrey's body don't
think that's gonna happen this time from
the pictures we've seen it looks like
it's just gonna be a lot more grand just
because so many more people were afraid
of time when he was such a bigger figure
in the history of Westeros then Joffrey
was so all the nobles show up just to
gawk because they're shocked that he
died before they did just because
someone like time when you expect them
to outlive everyone just out of spite
then you have the peasantry that are
just there for the spectacle plus you
have a situation where the poor become
incredibly disenfranchised since Stannis
is siege in the Battle of Blackwater
that seemed like it was a long time ago
but things have just gotten worse and
worse and worse for the poor that's
really where the high Sparrow comes in
but it looks like we don't see a lot of
him till episode 3 but the first episode
tends to hit all the bases like we see a
little bit from each of the big new
characters really that first episode is
just meant to set up the rest of the
season like everything you need to solve
what's going to happen in the valley
usually get set up in that first episode
so it's always fun to go back and watch
that first episode after you've watched
the season finale each year to see if
they gave you all the clues you needed
to solve what was going to happen in the
finale it doesn't always happen that way
but I mean if the writers have done
their job and they've cut like a really
tight arc that's usually what you can
expect and in the same is actually true
for the season one premiere for like the
pilot episode and the series finale so
it'll be fun you know after like season
7 or 8 to see if in that pilot all the
prophecies all the clues we needed to
solve like what was going to happen with
the entire series we're in there it's
like you open a story with the set of
characters doing something specific and
you end with that same group of
characters that doesn't mean everyone's
gonna make it but yeah I mean I think
we're all expecting a snow
garyun and maybe someone else to end up
in that series finale i think george RR
martin i'll have it easier time doing
that as big as is the book series has
gotten dan a day will have but i think
that's what they're trying to land on so
just moving down the description varus
reveals a conspiracy to Tyrion I know
everyone's asking about young Griff but
yeah I definitely still think that he's
been cut out of the series the
conspiracy is still relatively the same
they just they're swapping the young
Griff character for denise's character
or i should say combining it's a bigger
change to viruses character than it is
deterrence character but that's probably
just the moment where he reveals what he
and Illyrio had been working on the
whole time he's been behind enemy lines
waging a shadow war or preparing for a
war that nobody in King's Landing saw
coming with a few exceptions I think
there are a few people on the small
Council in season one that were worried
about Daenerys especially when she had
Khal Drogo now it seems since Tywin is
gone no one is thinking about her so
i'll be really interested to see if
there are any small council moments with
the new small council like the new
makeup that actually address what she's
doing in marine Cersei doesn't strike me
as much of a battle planner and now that
Tywin is gone she's in charge then it
says Danny faces a new threat to her
role I think it's funny that they use
the word Danny they shorten it that's
probably just talking about the sons of
the harpy we haven't met the harpy
although there are a lot of theories
about about who that is in the books
they might change who that is on the
show I would say the show is gonna back
anyone as the harpy it's gonna be his
door just because he's go Skary the sons
of the harpy are ghiscari order as much
conflict is going to be going on in
marine in season five as much you know
infighting between the slaves and the
slave masters I think that a lot of that
is going to be saved for winds of winter
so we might not see like big pitched
battles until season six I know there
were a lot of complaints last year that
Denise's story and marine was a little
anticlimactic I mean we had some dragons
add a little bit of complex in pitch
battle the beginning but they just they
did not end on like major WTF moments
like some of the other places did I
think her story in season 5 will have
some good responses to that based on
what we've seen from behind the scenes
will definitely get fighting pits as
we've seen in the trailer and will
probably end where her story ends and
dance with dragons so if you're reading
that book right now we should make it
through her entire story in that book
they've already released some info about
what's going on in marine and winds of
winter
but i'll save that for a future video
moving on to jon snow in the north when
it says jon is caught between two kings
that's referring to Stannis and Mance
Rayder the wildlings in Stannis's horses
in the Nights Watch are still two very
separate groups they haven't United yet
so even though Stannis was able to help
the Nights Watch win their battle that
doesn't mean that they're all hugging
each other it's gonna be a John's job to
bring Stannis and Mance Rayder together
to bring their causes together not that
Mance Rayder is gonna be buddies with
Stannis or anything like that but he's
just gonna have to unite the wildlings
and Stannis's forces wall Stan this is
still in charge there's there's no way
he's going to give up command regardless
of who takes command of the Nights Watch
now that the old bear is dead Stannis is
still the number one man up at the wall
but before they can deal with any
potentially white Walker threats they
had to deal with their internal problems
and don't forget the Bolton's are taking
their army to Winterfell so they're
going to be really close to the Nights
Watch in Stannis's army so worse to come
implies obviously you know white Walker
wore up the wall their continued war
against the wildlings a potential war
against the Bolton's then in King's
Landing you have a potential war with
the Tyrells things are still heating up
between the Tyrells and the Lannisters
or the crown or however you want to
think about it then in the south we have
Dorne which doesn't appear in the
synopsis but I do expect us to visit
dorm briefly in this episode there's
their potential war against the
Lannisters their war of revenge and then
in the East you have de nurses war
against the slave masters and the people
in youkai they employment at the end of
the last season if I didn't mention it
already the wise masters have taken
power again in young kya since she left
that's one of the big problems that
denise has like she fries a bunch of
people and then all the people she
defeated just rush back in the minute
she leaves it's a big problem slavers
Bay still big problem in season 5 that's
what that line comes from I'm going to
break the wheel like she wants to stop
the cycle of slavery but that's a way
bigger goal than she realizes moving on
to episode 2 the house of black and
white this is actually pretty exciting
we've actually seen a picture of the
house of black and white at least from
the outside the actual door itself arya
arrives in Braavos so this looks like
we're going to see her enter the temple
don't know how much we'll see of it in
this episode of all the book storylines
they're doing I think Arya's will be the
least changed so if you're a big fan of
re and bravos in the books they should
be able to hit most of the big moments
and they have
confirmed that the actor that played
Jack and hogar has been cast in season
five I think there were a lot of
questions about it because he wasn't
seen on set but he could be playing the
kindly man he could be playing someone
else either way I think that he'll be
there as part of Arya's plot they've
also confirmed that the waif is going to
be part of this season too I don't think
that every single character from the
house of black and white will be in
there from the books but most of the big
ones the kindly man is really like the
biggest one moving on to pod and brianne
Potter Brienne run into trouble on the
road this is where things are a little
bit different brand story is is slightly
different than it is in the books I know
a lot of people are hoping for Lady
Stoneheart I don't think we're gonna see
them but in terms of threats that they
could still run into they could still
run into the Brotherhood without banners
because they're not too far away from
where they could be or they could run
into little finger and Santa's forces
they're going to be touring around with
young Robin just to avoid suspicion
remember Littlefinger is keeping Sansa's
identity a secret so no one knows who
she is in the Eyrie the last time we saw
breanne she was fighting the Hound in
the Eyrie so it makes sense that if they
run into trouble it has something to do
with Littlefinger and Sansa but it could
always be some WTF surprise moving out
to Cersei looks like we're going to see
more Dorne in this episode so she fears
for her daughter's safety in Dorne is
ilaria San seeks revenge for Oberon's
death so the laureus and character
they're changing a little bit from the
books just like they changed the shake
character they're just they're giving
her more story they said that they saw
the actress in season 4 and they loved
her so much like she was so good that
they just wanted to use her more than
she was used in the books as a character
the same thing happened with Shay like
the actors just like nailed it out of
the park at least in their eyes so they
tried to do more with her so they're
basically giving all of the Aryan
Martel's story too ilaria sand I guess
if you like the actress that's a good
thing if you don't then it's gonna suck
but I think she's a great actress I
really liked her on Luther she didn't
have a really big part in season 4 great
reaction shot though great reaction shot
to Oberyn Martell vs the mountain then
moving back up to the North says Stannis
temps John there's really only a few
things that Stannis could tempt Jon Snow
with one he can make him head of the
Nights Watch to he could legitimize him
and make him John Stark in official heir
to Winterfell there could be a play
against the Bolton's claim on Winterfell
marika tempt him with the idea that if
he deals with the problem at hardhome
with the wildlings at hardhome then
he'll give him the mantle of leadership
technically that's something that they
usually do internally like they vote for
the next leader really what I'd like to
see his standards say I legitimize you
you won't be a bastard anymore that
would be a nice parallel to the Ramsay
snow storyline because he was
legitimized by Roose Bolton so now he's
Ramsay Bolton bastards moving up in the
world in season 5 and then here when it
says an advisor temps de nearest it
probably has something to do with
marrying his dorm remember the nobles of
marine are still very much entrenched
tanaris has been trying to deal with
them since she moved in like all the
slave masters all the really wealthy
families one way to appease them would
be to marry one of them Dario obviously
really against the idea of generis
getting married to anyone else not that
I think that he would be down to marry
her he does not seem like the marrying
kind and then on to episode 3 the high
Sparrow obviously fairly
self-explanatory can he get the deep
dive into Jonathan prices character I'm
really excited at the idea of a Bond
villain playing a really pious man the
high Sparrow is this really interesting
character I've already done a video on
him so I'll include a link in the
description if you want to learn more
about him from the books but he's
basically like Circe's worst nightmare
like he's someone that can't be bought
someone who really hates the trappings
of wealth he really is a man of the
people so it's gonna be interesting to
see Cersei try to deal with them if the
term confuses you high Sparrow is just
the new High Septon he is the third that
we've seen on the series so far the
first one like that the fat one was the
one that got yanked out blimp from limb
whenever the peasants rioted when
Joffrey was waking his way through town
the second High Septon is the one that
Tyrion appointed after that one had died
that was when Tyrion was still hand of
the King so Serge he's going to have
something of an internal war inside
King's Landing it's gonna be more of a
personal war it's not going to be like a
pitched battle so the title that first
episode words that come is is much more
relevant there's gonna be small personal
Wars and then there'll be big Wars with
actual armies so I guess you could make
that the subtitle for season 5 war is
coming war in lots of winter although
technically winter has already come in
the books winter like in terms of season
starts right around the time Joffrey
dies I don't think that they've made
that very clear on the show they might
they might address that they kind of a
loosely refer to the seasons but not as
much as they did in season 1 but that's
only the first three episodes will
probably learn the titles for the rest
of them within the next couple weeks
we're within a month of the show
starting so things are going to start
ramping up
quickly in the HBO streaming service
that should debut at the beginning of
April so that's actually that'll be what
my giveaway is whenever we start instead
of giving away just like copies of the
DVD i'll be giving away subscriptions to
the streaming service it's only going to
be 15 bucks mostly you should be able to
enjoy that some of you might have to use
like a VPN work around if you live in
international countries but you should
be able to pay the fifteen dollars and
enjoy it just like everyone else so
unless like some some big crazy news
drops between now and next week my next
bonus video is going to be another
character video be sure to subscribe to
get that feel free to leave your request
unlike which character you want me to do
it on but if you haven't seen them yet
you can click here for my sansa video
that i did last week and you can click
here for my Jon Snow video thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight for walking dead now let's all
do the thing
you